I don't want to go into the specifics of each of the grammar of
graphics very abstract principles as seen here as variables, and algebra,
scales, statistics, geometry, coordinates, aesthetics, and our renderer.
And even though you may think you're familiar with variables,
in the context of the grammar of graphics this is slightly different than
JavaScript variables for example.
And while you may think you understand geometry and
possibly have studied it in school, the geometry of the grammar of graphics
specifies is slightly different than the geometry many people are familiar with.
Hopefully by tying each of these very abstract principles to associate d3
concepts, such as the d3 data loading, the d3 scale link.
Appending rectangles, circles and lines and using CSS to
style a graphic we can make the grammar of graphics theory much more concrete.
Also, since d3 has a very chainable API this concept of a pipeline
fits very naturally with how d3 creates graphics to render on a webpage.